let's start today with Vladimir Putin
and Russia we know that Russian
casualties are mounting we know that
Russia is being drastically affected by
sanctions even if they are undertaking a
public relations campaign to try to make
the case that they're fine and
everything's fine and the latest in this
uh
seemingly interminable Fiasco is Putin
and Russia claiming that the United
States is actually behind an alleged
Ukrainian drone attack which I guess
damaged a flagpole and did nothing else
whereas intelligence analysts are saying
it is far more likely that this is a
Russian false flag than it is something
with American involvement particularly
because it failed so badly if indeed the
goal was to hurt somebody and it's just
blatantly pathetic in terms of the video
that has been released so let's go
through this in pieces NBC news report
Russia claims the U.S is behind the
alleged Ukrainian drone attack on the
Kremlin both Kiev and Washington
strongly denied involvement
in what Moscow said without citing
evidence was an attempt to assassinate
President Vladimir Putin Russia claimed
Thursday the U.S was behind the alleged
drone attack on the Kremlin and said it
was a Ukrainian attempt to kill Putin
this accusation was made without citing
any evidence a less than 24 hours after
Moscow said that it foiled an overnight
drone strike on a building that is the
heart of the country's government and
Putin's residence Kremlin spokesman
Dmitry peskov quite a node of
disinformation claimed Thursday that
Washington Mastermind masterminded the
incident the U.S swiftly rejected the
accusation saying it had nothing to do
with it as did Ukraine now there is
another very interesting piece a CNBC uh
Slash NBC report analysts say Russia
quote likely staged Kremlin drone attack
it blamed on Ukraine and the West
speculation is mounting that Russia
staged the Drone attack on the Kremlin
that it blamed on Ukraine with political
analysts saying there are a number of
reasons why the alleged strike which
Russia called a planned terrorist attack
just doesn't add up Russia accused
Ukraine of attempting to attack the
Kremlin saying the government and Kiev
tried to strike at the heart of Russia's
government
Russian President Putin wasn't injured
in what it characterized as an
assassination attempt in fact Putin had
not been in the Kremlin at the time of
the alleged incident but provided no
evidence Ukraine carried it out Ukraine
denied involvement Russia has often been
accused of plotting false flag attacks
that it can blame on Ukraine and used to
justify or escalate its own military
aggression against the country as the
war drags on into its 15 months so what
do we actually know I mean we know that
there was something on video that looks
like a drone
um it appears as though it hit a
flagpole
Moscow claims it was Ukraine trying to
kill Putin masterminded by the United
States there's no evidence of that
Ukraine denies it the U.S denies it
analysts say it was likely staged now
let's believe it for a second and what I
mean by that is let's believe for a
second that this really was an attempt
by Ukraine masterminded by the United
States to kill Putin couple different
things one we have to believe that an
attack masterminded by the United States
and carried out by Ukraine hit a
flagpole okay not the most uh uh
predictable outcome that we would
imagine
and or secondly
we have to believe that Russia is
admitting that their air defense system
is so poor that enemy drones now just
fly over the Capitol and hit a flagpole
at the Kremlin both of these scenarios
certainly taken together
aren't super easy to believe
and what we do know is that there's a
very long history with Vladimir Putin of
false flag type events of this kind used
to justify whatever and you can go all
the way back to Putin's Ascension to
power with examples of that probably a
topic for another day what we know is
that Russia continues to have huge
losses
Russia believed this would be super easy
when it started last year 15 months ago
and it's probably not easy to keep the
Russian public patriotic and happy as
family members and friends and loved
ones Etc are being killed as a result of
what was supposed to be a very easy
takeover of Ukraine so from a PR
perspective it would be extraordinarily
useful to be able to credibly claim that
the Ukraine with a masterminded by the
United States Ukraine carried out such
an attacker attempted attack and the key
line in all of this is that Russia says
it will respond
what does a response mean what will that
response look like well we don't know
yet but that often is the name of the
game uh create a pretext a surface of
pretext to then justify further
escalations and maybe have a PR impact
to get more people on the side of this
completely hair brained incursion by
Putin and Ukraine when you ask me how
will it end I still have absolutely no
idea
but it's looking like it's going to be
relatively ugly Republicans are now
accusing President Joe Biden of bribery
with absolutely zero evidence Marjorie
Taylor green uh Sean Hannity Chuck
Grassley Senators members of Congress
right-wing media they're all saying we
might even be getting to impeachment of
Biden now oh what exactly did he do well
we don't know what's the evidence well
we don't have any yeah let me explain to
you the back story of what's going on
Joe Biden Accused by whistleblower of
bribery scheme with foreign National
this is reported by Newsweek and many
others a pair of top republicans in
Congress this is the base of the story a
pair of top republicans in Congress
issued a subpoena for records They say
might and the word might is doing a lot
of work here might detail a criminal
scheme involving then Vice President Joe
Biden and a foreign National
the White House says it's unfounded and
that the claims are motivated by
political bias when you look at who's at
the center of this it's Iowa Republican
senator Chuck Grassley and Kentucky
Republican representative James Comer
James Comer for months now probably
years in fact has been saying Biden's
guilty of what well we don't know yet
but he's guilty and now they've got
something they have an alleged
whistleblower making a claim that as of
yet is completely unsubstantiated now
they're going to they've issued a
subpoena they're going to look for
evidence and as I've said before I'm
going to speak very clearly and slowly
here if there is evidence
investigate if the investigate points to
crimes prosecute and if there is a
conviction sentence that applies to Joe
Biden it applies to Hunter Biden it
applies to Hillary Obama Trump
that is my perspective on all of this
but we have to at some point say
do we have any evidence whatsoever
for what is right now an allegation from
a whistleblower the answer is no but
that doesn't stop all sorts of the usual
clowns from coming out and saying it's
time we're going to impeach him now you
might say David there really aren't
credible news outlets taking this
seriously right now and that's right
because there is no evidence at this
point in time so let's start with
Marjorie Taylor green she appeared on
Lindell TV's Frank speech war room
yeah I I don't know
um she says uh we're we're getting close
to impeachment now well this is where
where is blinking
money to make real policy decisions uh
on behalf of the United States it's pay
to play this is a true crime and this
was Joe Biden when he was vice president
of the United States when Joe Biden took
a money payment from a foreign National
in exchange for policy decisions
understand there's no evidence for any
of this he was vice president
will be impeached and that's the
evidence that we've undercut we have cut
we have now understand there's no
evidence there's just an alleged
whistleblower that's all there is found
out under in only a few months a few
months time we were able to do this
they've undercovered it it's not even a
question of uncovering it they've
undercovered it God for the American
people that voted for republicans in the
majority and give us the gavel so that
we could have subpoena power to go after
the Biden crime family and everything
they have done to sell out this country
now remember that Marjorie Taylor green
was drafting articles for impeaching Joe
Biden before any of this stuff came out
to begin with and now they have
something to latch on to Ted Cruz of
course a Bastion of Sanity sober uh
reasoning and and uh moral
being an upstanding moral citizen Ted
Cruz appeared on Sean Hannity's
propaganda program on Fox News and they
are also talking about impeaching Biden
without having any evidence or substance
whatsoever from Grassley and comer yeah
and they're saying that they believe the
doj and the FBI possess an unclassified
fd-1023 that describes that an alleged
criminal scheme involving they're not by
the way alleged is doing a lot of work
here they're not even all they're saying
is they have a whistleblower claiming it
that's all then Vice President Biden and
a foreign National relating to the
exchange of money for a policy decision
uh that would be a high crime and
misdemeanor Senator it it absolutely
would in fact it doesn't have to be a
high crime or misdemeanor because the
Constitution specifies that impeachment
lies for treason bribery or other high
crimes investigators bribery is
explicitly noted they're fine in the
Constitution and and I got to say the
evidence not only against Hunter Biden
but the evidence against Joe Biden being
complicit and profiting from this
corruption is growing and growing and
growing every week on my podcast I've
verdict with Ted Cruz I've walked
listeners through yeah that's a hell of
a podcast by the way so they're talking
about impeachment they've seen no
evidence either Pastor I'm sorry uh
Senator Josh Hawley not Pastor Josh
Hawley Senator Josh Hawley admits he
hasn't actually seen any of the evidence
but it should still be up to Democrats
to prove Biden is innocent which isn't
exactly the way I remember burden of
proof working in the United States you
know senator who do we think the other
country is they we we knew the Chinese
connection and all that but this isn't
this is something new do you have any
information on that no I do not
isn't that and the funny thing is that's
the answer for all of these guys I
actually don't have any information but
we definitely need to impeach by
information on what the whistleblowers
has alleged in terms of the specific
substantive allegations right other than
that there is documentation that the FBI
has and I just say again to those
Democrats here out there screaming about
how Joe Biden is innocent Joe Biden
hasn't done anything well fine then show
us what you know show us what the
evidence is and the allegations don't be
afraid of what the facts are there you
go so Josh Hawley making the case that
he doesn't have anything but it's up to
Democrats to demonstrate innocence
um then Chuck Grassley did also appear
on Fox News Chuck Grassley is one of the
main people here uh Chuck Grassley and
James Comer issuing the subpoena here to
the alleged whistleblower for the
allegations that they are making about
okay he is pressed about evidence and he
says well we have to wait we're
wondering exactly what this is all about
according to a press release that was
sent out by James cummer's office
assistant information provided by a
whistleblower raises concerns the then
Vice President Biden allegedly engaged
in a bribery scheme with a foreign
National it goes on to say the American
people need to know if President Biden
sold out the United States to make money
for himself Senator Grassley and I will
seek the truth to ensure accountability
for the American people well that really
what's our appetite is to exactly what
what this is all about does this have to
do with Hunter Biden's foreign business
dealing with Ukraine or China or is it
something else well I I guess basically
uh we we've got to wait to see what what
the document exactly says right but I
convinced that uh we've got to get this
detail ill and at this time the FBI
needs to explain whether it's accurate
or not yeah uh did they learn nothing
from the Dominion lawsuit and the 787.5
million dollar settlement over on Fox
News and then we have one from Newsmax
as well uh Newsmax is very very
concerned about this as I'm sure you can
imagine wait it says specifically the
release today that the vice president
may have altered policy
for money a primary scheme he may have
actually changed policy have you
narrowed it down to what policies or can
you at least tell me if you have
what area if you can't say specifically
what do you know about it sir uh
Congressman Fallon
well Greg that'll all come out I think
and it'll come out very soon just like
it's going to come out when with Trump's
health care plan is my guess oh minus
let's ask another question very simple
one what business what product or
service did the bidens ever provide yeah
there you go that's a real serious
question so listen as I've said before
do you have actual evidence against Joe
Biden Hunter Biden investigate uh turns
out there there were crimes it was
legitimate charge Biden charge Hunter
Biden charged Joe Biden I don't care I
don't care about defending anybody I
don't care about cults of personality
around any of these folks if Bernie
committed a crime charge Bernie okay
it's been years of this stuff and the
evidence is just on the tip of our
tongues be just beyond the reach of our
hands and yet it doesn't happen so I'm
reminded of when I think of this
whistleblower I'm reminded of remember
that I believe the guy's name was Tony
bobolinski or something like that who
was just going to deliver this Hammer
blow of uh evidence against
um I don't even remember who it was it
was going to clear Trump and all and
then he was interviewed like twice on
Fox and then you never heard from him
again because it was all completely
bogus if you've got the evidence let's
see it but are they really going to do
this for the rest of Joe Biden's term
the answer is absolutely yes they are
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
Florida Republicans have passed a
disgusting and I would argue completely
unenforceable pronoun Bill pronoun bill
as well as a ban on diversity programs
now I'm going to give you the details
and I'll tell you why this doesn't make
any sense but if you zoom out just a
little bit remember we've been talking
about this Florida Fiasco for months now
and aside from being completely morally
bankrupt and substantively vapid it also
seems to be the wrong strategic approach
politically for Florida Republicans to
focus so much on Disney's bad and woke
is bad and trans is bad because they
don't really have the voters on their
side to a great degree with these issues
but okay this is what they've decided to
do so what have they done the Associated
Press reports Florida Republicans pass
bill on pronoun usage at school ban on
diversity programs and you might be
saying have they banned a part of speech
completely no they're talking about
gender pronouns that differ from
biological sex and I'll tell you the
exact wording in a moment Florida
Republicans on Wednesday approved bills
to ban diversity programs and colleges
and prevent students and teachers from
being required to use pronouns that
don't correspond to someone's sex built
on top priorities of Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis the two proposals were
given final passage by the Republican
super majorities DeSantis is expected to
sign it
um okay so what does it do the Senate
Wednesday voted to expand the law
critics called don't say gay a major
calling card of DeSantis with a sweeping
bill that prevents School staffers or
students from being required to refer to
People by pronouns that don't respond to
the correspond to the person's sex it
also bans classroom instruction on
gender identity and sexual orientation
up to the eighth grade legally
reinforcing the DeSantis move to
prohibit such lessons in all grades it
also strengthens the system in which
people can Lodge challenges against
school books another disantemonious de
sanctimonious initiative all right so
there's a problem here okay and I know
many of you already identify it the only
way to know whether you were using the
pronouns that correspond to biological
birth sex is to know what genitals
someone has how on Earth would teachers
ascertain that and so when you say well
you just can't force the teachers to use
pronouns that don't correspond to the
genitalia of the individual
and I guess they're saying the birth
genitalia right there's another story
when you talk about gender affirming
surgery but let's not even delve into
that right now you're saying you can't
require them well how is anyone to know
whether what is being asked of them with
regard to pronouns matches the genitals
without taking a look at the genitals or
or what requiring a birth certificate so
obviously this is a provision that's
discriminatory to the trans Community
it's harmful to the trans Community it's
also completely impractical in every
single way because you're telling
teachers in order to know
about whether the pronouns you're using
are the right ones
you I guess have to ascertain biological
sex by looking at people are they
supposed to ask students for medical
records before addressing them by the
correct pronouns so this is not only a
ridiculous virtue signal against trans
people for the anti-trans community to
look and say oh we like what you're
doing it is a logistical and practical
nightmare for educators and it's not
feasible to enforce and of course it
goes against the very principles of
inclusivity and acceptance that we
should promote and be promoting in our
schools this doesn't mean by the way
this doesn't mean or it doesn't even
relate in any way to whether someone
born biologically male who identifies as
a woman should be allowed to be on the
girls wrestling team that's a totally
separate question it has nothing to do
with this now I also briefly want to
talk about the ban on diversity programs
because that's also a part of this even
though it's less cartoonish although
still destructive
it's equally concerning diversity
programs are designed to promote
inclusivity and to promote understanding
among different cultures and communities
the right loves to say that those
programs actually suppress speech bully
people
Etc to the extent that you give me an
example of that I am on your side and I
will be against it you all know if
you've been listening to this program
for a while that I don't go for that
stuff
when the left goes too far as the right
loves to say I'll just tell you yeah I
don't agree with this this is not in the
spirit of progressivism this is not in
the spirit of
um uh libertarian progressivism of the
style that I and so many other
Progressive support those instances are
relatively rare and when you say no
diversity programs whatsoever you're
Banning programs that actually provide
significant value and they promote
understanding among different groups in
a way that is completely not it's not
only harmless it's a positive thing
um this is what Florida Republicans are
now focused on I believe that not only
is it wrong morally
but it's also a strategic mistake in
that they're overplaying their hand that
second part it will take some time for
us to get an answer are they overplaying
their hand we will soon see but one of
the next questions which was raised by
someone in our audience is what follows
this and one possibility is that they go
after LGBT teachers I want to talk about
that next all right uh very interesting
post to the David pakman show subreddit
Yesterday by a user named s Daga
and S Daga asks the question will
conservatives go after
lgbtq plus teachers next all the
rhetoric about keeping kids quote safe
from LGBT people is ridiculous I worry
they might actually start targeting
folks whose job it is to work with
children parents want to screen
curriculum their child is presented is
screening of their child's teacher next
the school I recently retired from had
about 75 professional staff several
identify as gay or bi one is a trans man
one teacher is married to a trans man
LGBT people are in all our communities I
think that it is almost a certainty that
we are going to start seeing this at
least anecdotally around the country
it's probably already happening uh
anecdotally to some degree
think about it okay the transition think
about the things they're already saying
uh discussions of LGBT people sexual
orientation transgender
Etc that's already bad it's off the
table it's dangerous okay drag shows
drag time story hour all these different
things very very bad can't do it can't
do it using the pronouns that a student
wants to go by
shouldn't do it it's very bad should
always use pronouns that match
biological sex at Birth I guess they
mean at Birth
the natural next thing would be to say
not only is it dangerous to kids to hear
discussion of LGBT topics and the fact
that LGBT people exist
it must be so irresistible for LGBT
teachers to talk about it that we have
to be worried about the mere presence of
LGBT teachers in the classroom
seems perfectly logical if you follow
the deranged Republican logic they will
use the same tired arguments that we've
heard for many years they'll say well
listen children at age eight shouldn't
be around any sexualization or
indoctrination and when I see my kids
gay teacher or trans teacher it is
highly sexual and it is an
indoctrination so we've got to get rid
of them now of course they just want to
silence and punish teachers who are
openly LGBT many of them probably
believe if my kid's teacher is LGBT it
might convince or brainwash my kid into
being LGBT or whatever the case may be
and it's really important to understand
that they already are using the framing
of danger to children and parents rights
and so they are simply going to adapt
that existing terminology to LGBT
teachers listen I don't want my kid
recruited I don't want my kids
development
stifled in any way I don't want this
ideology pushed on them I don't want any
of it now these arguments are of course
baseless but they are so deeply harmful
to people who are either openly part of
the LGBT community
um or not yet openly part of it they are
discriminatory in I believe at this
point every state it would be and it's
really important to understand that
these attacks on teachers who identify
as LGBT will just be the latest attempt
to do the things that they wanted to do
all along we should stigmatize LGBT
status we should marginalize those
individuals and they've already passed
bills and laws of All Sorts to do that
including don't say gay so to the
question are they going to go after the
LGBT teachers next
I'm not a betting man but I would bet
that at least at the local level on some
small scale we're going to see it if not
through legislation more broadly let me
know what you think
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well as
many of you know every two or three
months we have a last minute
cancellation or a no-show or a problem
with a guest and it's unfortunate but it
is impossible to prevent 100 when that
happens I say let's hear from a few
people in the audience so let's do that
now of course we take calls via Discord
at davidpackman.com Discord let's start
with Mitchell from Ohio Mitchell what's
on your mind today what can I do for you
hi David I've been thinking a lot
recently about how most people on
opposite sides of the political Spectrum
have more in common with each other than
they will ever have with people who have
a vast amount of influence and Power in
this country true and I just can't seem
to wrap my head around how we get people
to understand that their interests are
more aligned than they think I don't
know the answer to that either and you
know what the first time that this was
like very
um evident to me was that in a movement
I covered closely it was the 2010 the
growth of the Tea Party Movement and
Jonathan height has written a lot about
this where a lot of it has to do with
you're not thinking in terms of what is
actually best for me and the vast
majority of people including people who
supposedly are on the opposite political
side you're thinking in terms of my team
you're thinking in terms of the people
who I sort of take direction from what
are they telling me to do what are they
saying is best and I I genuinely don't
know a lot of this has very deep
psychology
um written into it as Jonathan height
has written about and I don't because
you're absolutely right on so many
issues particularly economic issues even
if we put aside social issue differences
the vast majority of Americans actually
have the same interests and would
benefit from the same policies and yet
they are split between two political
parties
I'd I'd have to agree with you I and if
you ask anyone from either party or
either side of the aisle I feel like
most people just want to be able to put
in an honest day's work for an honest
day's wage should come home to their
family and do it again the next day and
put a little money aside but I do you
think that there's truth to that there's
an artificial culture War being started
by you know people like Rhonda santis to
try and stop people from seeing the
economic uh issues that they actually
have in common that's one way to put it
I the way and I don't think you're wrong
the way I've said it is a little
different which is the country keeps
moving left on policy particularly
Economic Policy so what the right has
done is abandon policy particularly
economic policy and do the culture War
so I don't know that it's overtly to
prevent people from realizing that's an
interesting perspective but I think it's
basically if it was just about policy
Republic Pelicans would have a even
tougher time winning elections so they
make it about something else instead but
it's basically the same thing you're
saying
yeah it's all it's all very interesting
I appreciate your perspective thank you
for taking my call all right Mitchell
from Ohio very important and well said I
appreciate that let's go to David from
Florida David from Florida uh what's
going on I may be making my uh
triumphant return to Florida very soon
up next what are you headed usually at
the Miami area
okay it's a little too crowded for for
my face
I just had uh two questions for you sure
uh one your opinion on the fact that it
seems neither of the parties are going
to be participating in uh debates at
least at least the Republican conference
did say that you know they would have
one it's just Trump may not be
participating uh but the fact that Biden
doesn't even want to talk to
um Marianne or Kennedy kind of seems a
little messed up for me yeah I mean
listen
um I would like to see debates on both
sides I think Trump not showing up is
pathetic and I think that the DNC
um should organize debates but I'm also
not naive obviously why if you are if
you have an incumbent president and you
have as a priority making the incumbent
president president for four more years
why would you take the risk and I know
people say well if it were Obama there
would be less risk because Obama's
better and speak public speaking than by
whatever why would you create a
situation with the risk that your
eventual nominee ends up hurting
themselves with a bad debate performance
it's sort of like obviously I I'm always
for debate and more conversation but
it's also so obvious that it would be a
completely unforced risk for the DNC to
to try to force Biden to debate
and you 've been uh uh his you know age
and the fact that he has uh seemingly
more difficulty to speak uh not that you
know he doesn't get anything done he
does it's just it's a little bit more
public appearances you know it's not
doing as good as he used to yeah but
it's not it's not because I mean the
when you have an incumbent uh running
for re-election
you don't do debates
if he does go to the debate and he gets
he gets you know troused it just makes
him you know look even worse as the
incumbent so people would be more likely
to you know vote otherwise try I I
completely understand what you're saying
yeah all right my second thing was oh
about uh the Florida Senate Bill 7050
where they slipped in the fact that you
can now uh run for other office uh if
you're running for the presidency
I actually did not see that but I know
that there was a discussion of changing
that and of course it's specifically for
um for Ron DeSantis yeah I didn't I
actually didn't see that that passed
yeah fair and cousins actually just did
a video about it
um it was last Friday I believe that
they put it through of course behind
closed doors saying that you know if you
were to run for office and other you
know other offices like that would you
know you'd have to uh resign first
resign to run
um and then they put in if you're going
for the presidency nah that's totally
cool go for it yeah well I mean listen
we all know the whole point of that I
still don't know a hundred percent
whether DeSantis is or isn't going to
announce I mean I think he probably will
but I think it's possible he'll get
talked out of it but it's very clear
that they're setting the stage for him
to run if he wants to
um we can only help when he does it
might pull away a little bit of uh some
Republican votes but uh we'll we'll see
what happens in 24. thanks for taking my
call all right David from Florida there
he goes let's go next to LJ from Las
Vegas LJ from Las Vegas welcome to the
program what's on your mind
hey David how you been doing well
good
um I have a kind of a rough cut on
something so it's not 100 thought
through but I just kind of want to get
your thought on it if that's cool sure
um so I know that we always talk about
like every single year um the black
community being a very big part of the
democratic party and like one of the
most reliable voting blocks for you know
Democrats in a sense yes I kind of
wondered what's some of the things that
we can do because I'm Hispanic myself
right to activate more Hispanic people
more you know Mexicans more Cubans more
um just the the Block in general to kind
of create more you know um
discussion around like you know opening
the border for people who are good you
know and again this is again a run a
rough cut of an idea so I just kind of
want to get your point of view on that
well here's the thing one of the things
that I try to resist is assuming that in
order to get a certain group involved
you need to cater or Pander with
particular issues above and beyond the
general idea that there are all sorts of
different reasons why they should be
engaged with politics now obviously we
can't ignore that different groups have
different priorities so if a population
that is more likely to have family in
Central and South America is almost
certainly going to be more motivated by
certain issues than people that don't
and that might relate to everything from
so-called chain migration to DACA
permanent status all these different
things but one of the things I think is
really important is if we identify not
necessarily a group but people who
aren't engaging politically
first we should be having a general
conversation about why aren't you
engaged why aren't you voting whatever
the case may be before automatically
jumping to like for example if there
were a bunch of say uh gay men who
weren't voting I wouldn't necessarily go
straight in on LGBT rights for example I
would first just want to know why aren't
you why aren't you engaged because the
reason they're not engaged may actually
not be related specifically to issues of
LGBT rights and obviously it's important
to say hey it might be of particular
importance for you to get involved
because right now one party actually
wants to strip right specifically from
folks based on an identity that you
share but I would start with the more
General reasons to be involved
politically
definitely it's just it's interesting
because as someone who grew up here in
Vegas right
um in Nevada it's 20 of the population
is Hispanic right
um and within Nevada state um
accordingly to the Census Bureau so you
know I don't know how accurate that is
but that's at least the numbers that I
can record yeah I don't have them in
front of me I'll take your word for it
yeah um but um in that sense right um I
do feel like there's always this
assumption that the Hispanic Vote or at
least in my personal view that
um people don't think it's as important
or as valued as let's say the black Vote
or the mothers in Suburban neighborhoods
right and my thought is why couldn't
there be a discussion more to include
um Hispanic families um Nevada or Elise
Las Vegas has one of the best unions in
the entire country right The Culinary
Workers Union Yes and I feel like as
Hispanics that's a very big thing that
we should be focusing on is increasing
the size of that Union and using Nevada
as a template for why unions should work
across the country I agree 100 and I as
a you know I was born in Argentina moved
to the U.S Hispanic immigrant et cetera
I agree with you 100 that it is a group
that
um I think should be it's not a question
of targeting but understood more
um and I I completely agree with
everything you're saying
cool thank you I appreciate it Dave all
right LJ from Las Vegas there he goes uh
let's go to oh I don't know how about uh
how about Chris from Texas Chris what's
going on today
you hear me yes I can
David yes can you hear me yes
can you hear me yes I can
okay okay so I guess that one thing I
was having a question about was what are
your thoughts on the Jordan Neely desk
you know I saw that um Eric Adams so
this is the death of uh this was a man
who was kill correct me if I'm wrong
Chris this is a man who was killed on a
New York City subway basically put in a
choke hold for like 10 minutes or
something like that after yeah 15 15
minutes you know and I want to be
careful here after maybe acting sort of
aggressively but it's like not really
totally clear right I mean I think that
this is kind of what there's debate over
and I saw Eric Adams the mayor of New
York City put out a statement that was
kind of quite weird just very
generically condemning tragedy but
um talking about mental illness and
things that are not not even totally
clear I I don't I'm kind of reserving
judgment because I just want to learn
more about it I read a couple stories
about it and I saw some statements but I
don't want to say anything wrong until I
know more
yeah I guess for me it just makes me
kind of a little worried just because I
guess for me I'm black and autistic as
well and I feel like I a lot of the
times when it comes to mental health our
country doesn't really do much service
for people that are in need of mental
health treatment or or who have or or or
who are in poverty as well and I kind of
feel like some of the policies that Eric
Adams has done when it comes to like
increasing police funding while cutting
like Social Services like for education
and likes and and health and health and
Healthcare and housing is kind of
probably exacerbated the problem in my
opinion well listen what I don't want to
do is to start characterizing the
incident as anything other than than
what it is it has the potential to
basically be a sort of vigilantism that
we should be extremely concerned about
it it has the possibility of being a
mental illness story as well I just I
just want to know more it is a tragedy
without a doubt but I want to know more
details before I kind of like give what
might be a more definitive take about it
but uh from what I've read and seen so
far extraordinarily concerning
yeah but I guess Also regarding a
vigilance vigilantism how can we
probably address like like with laws to
prevent more vigilante justice because I
feel like it's been getting out of hand
like especially I remember there was
this one kid who was shot from a what
from a white old white guy in from some
other state as well yeah the issue with
vigilantism is that it it
directly relates to
how self-defense laws are written and
enforced and that can include stand your
ground castle doctrine Etc so it really
comes down to state law on a lot of
those issues and you deal with people
people's willingness to participate in
vigilantism is going to directly relate
to their understanding of self-defense
law uh in their state and so that's the
context in which it needs to be thought
through
so probably we'll need to do something
more along the lines of trying to
educate people better in terms of how
self-defense laws work and also trying
to maybe change the voting the the laws
regarding self-defense as well in the
country potentially potentially and it
depends on state to state yeah Chris
thank you for bringing it up I
appreciate it
all right thank you for the call David
all right there goes Chris from Texas
thanks for uh calling in today we're
going to take a quick break and the
Thursday show is going to continue
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
this is super interesting one of the
most interesting interviews I've seen in
a while Nigel farage was a member of the
British Parliament under the ukip party
that's the UK independence party it's a
right-wing populist rhetoric type party
that has a lot of overlap with Maga
trumpism as disturbing and hilarious as
that is Nigel farage for a while has
been saying I don't think Trump should
keep talking about how 2020 was rigged
whether it was or wasn't rigged Trump
shouldn't keep talking about it it's not
going to help Trump win in 2024. Nigel
farage interviewed Trump and actually
said to him I wouldn't keep talking
about that and Trump kind of gets
defensive and says well listen I'm
talking about it because you brought it
up but then later says but it was rigged
okay let's dive into this interview
fascinating take a look at this
my point to you is if you're going to
win this next year in November 2024
you're not going to win it talking about
what happened last time
haven't you got a set of positive
message 100 you brought this up to me I
didn't bring it up today you know you
mentioned yourself yeah I said look it
was real and I say that I'll always say
that it doesn't mean that out of a
one-hour speech I'm going to devote half
of it to this I might have except he
kind of does 10 seconds to it but the
election was rigged it was a rigged
election it was a very dishonest
election I don't know that Nigel farage
is correct and what I mean by that is
when you survey Mega voters
they overwhelmingly believed that it was
rigged when you survey Republican voters
in general
they also to a lesser degree than the
hardcore Maga types but they also have
fallen for this idea that 2020 was
rigged so I don't have the answer
empirically as to whether in a general
election on balance the message that
2020 was rigged as part of a 2024
election brings voters in or pushes
voters away it's not obvious to me one
way or the other I think is the point
that I'm trying to make Trump continuing
with the election was rigged stuff even
during this interview the election was
rigged and Rupert Murdock should have
talked about it but Rupert Murdoch
doesn't believe he can win a court case
on that but Rupert Murdoch's wrong and
whoever settled this case for that much
money and I think it was an insult not
only to Fox it was an insult to all the
people that worked there it was an
insult to everybody that knows what
happened during that election number one
they didn't use the legislation number
two if you just look into modern times
just look over the last couple of months
the f FBI Delta with Twitter they go
with Twitter files understand none of
this it's not only that none of this
proves it was rigged none of this even
relates to the election in a direct way
that was cheating you look at look at
the 51 different I have no doubt look at
the 51 different intelligence agents
so-called intelligence agents they all
lied 100 they lied all of this stuff is
seating and then you look at truth to
vote where hundreds of thousands of
ballots were stuffed in the ballot boxes
they were stuffed with usually we do
like a ham and gruyere but they might
have stuffed them with something
different so Trump's legal advice
remember His Brilliant legal advice from
the guy who lost 60-something court
cases related to the 2020 election his
legal advice to Fox News was prove that
Trump really won and then by definition
it wouldn't have been defamation where
that that that
ultimately Fox's lawyers did not go that
way and they agreed to pay 787 and a
half million dollars to Dominion voting
systems other items from this interview
that are certainly interesting Trump
insisting that he will end the Russian
incursion into Ukraine within 24 hours
maybe in that wacky Town Hall that's
scheduled for next week Caitlin Collins
can ask exactly how would he do that I
will end that war in one day it'll take
24 hours I know zielinski well I know
Putin well
I would get that ended in a period of
you can break that deal 100 it would be
easy that deal would be easy a lot of it
has to do with the money a lot of it has
to do with the military you know Trump
would wrap it up quickly he would go
listen Ukraine goes to Putin it's now
part of Russia let's end this entire
thing uh in all seriousness I would love
for Trump to be pressed just once on
exactly how he would end that conflict
in 24 hours the topic of the coronation
of the new British king came up and
Trump says he was extraordinarily
surprised that Biden would not be
attending and Mr Biden's not coming what
does that say about his relationship
with the UK because we get the feeling
here yeah he's very very Pro Ireland he
completely ignores the fact that Biden
is in fact an English name he's got
English relatives he doesn't seem to
like us very much
I don't think he can do it physically
actually I think that it's hard for him
to do it physically I think getting over
here for him he's got a lot of things
going and a lot of strange things happen
but certainly he should be here as
our representative of our country I was
surprised when I heard that he wasn't
coming you would think he would be here
he'll be in Delaware where he spent a
lot of time he spent a lot of time there
during the election in the bunker so I
don't know but it's it is Bunker so
listen um there's a long-held tradition
that American Presidents don't go to
British coronations Jill Biden is going
and that's fine but there's actually
nothing particularly unusual about that
but again it's this is an alternate
universe sticking with the subject of
um Royal elements uh topics related to
the royal family Donald Trump said that
Meghan Markle treated the queen very
disrespectfully which uh I mean God this
this is uh
I think it's going to be a great day and
I think that they will do a great job
yeah and he loves the country really I
got to know him quite well and he loves
the country really loves the country and
he loved his mother
and that's why I thought it was she was
treated so disrespectfully by Megan and
just no reason to do that I was actually
surprised that
Harry was invited to be honest
there you go very very surprising and of
course Trump's the guy who truly
disrespected the former Queen
um he was late and kept her waiting and
then he gracelessly stepped in front of
her I mean just everything is backwards
everything is the opposite of what this
guy says and then lastly Nigel farage
asking Trump so are you going to win
next year and Trump's response not
exactly projecting huge confidence final
thought
are you going to win next year
I think we have a very good chance uh
the economy is not good I'll make it
good everyone knows you know everyone
knows even Democrats they say well we
agree that Putin would have never gone
in he wouldn't I don't you're not going
in so going into a word salad that's
unrelated after saying I think we've got
a shot Putin would have never gone into
Ukraine president XI of China would
never even be talking about Taiwan we
had that conversation strongly I stopped
uh North Korea from doing some really
bad things and my relationship all right
so he goes and talks about other stuff
Trump does something that is often seen
I I know that this is going to sound so
pejorative but I'm not I'm being totally
serious I'm not saying Trump is wildly
mentally ill or anything like that like
he might be but but I'm just not saying
it here
there is an observation that is often
done when someone is evaluated
psychiatrically about whether they have
this sort of like tangential thinking
and Trump has it to an incredible degree
where he simply asked are you going to
win next year and he talks about his
relationship with Kim Jong-un and it's
really I mean you call it a feature or a
bug of Trump's speech but it is there
very strongly so famous last words I
think we who's the we I think we have a
good chance at winning in 2024. bizarre
interview and all coming around the same
time that Trump got some very bad legal
news let's talk about that next a judge
has thrown out Donald Trump's lawsuit
against the New York Times and his own
niece Mary Trump this one I know many of
you have been following and some of you
may have forgotten about this was the
big lawsuit where Trump was going to
really take them to task a judge has
thrown the lawsuit out and is ordering
Trump to pay everybody else's legal fees
isn't this the best uh The Daily Beast
reporting
judge tosses Trump's lawsuit against New
York Times orders him to pay all legal
fees Trump sued the paper along with his
niece Mary alleging an Insidious plot to
grab his tax records and publish them in
a Pulitzer winning report the judge has
tossed out the lawsuit and ordered him
to pay attorney's fees legal expenses
and Associated costs this does go back
to 2021 when Trump filed the lawsuit
saying that the New York Times three of
its reporters and his own niece marry
Trump engaged in an Insidious plot to
obtain his private records for a
Pulitzer winning story about his tax
issues when the court tossed out Trump's
claims against the newspaper and its
reporters the claims while the court
tossed out those claims the claims
against the ex-president's niece have
yet to be ruled upon this is Justice uh
Supreme New York Supreme Court Justice
Robert Reed who said that the defendants
fail as a matter of constitutional law
and added that Trump has failed to
demonstrate any tortious interference
with the times when the times provided
his niece with a burner phone to
communicate about the records so another
instance of major winning by Trump as
you can see Trump's history with
lawsuits is really really tough Trump
paid 25 million dollars for his scam
Trump University you may recall that
Trump had to pay back two million
dollars for misusing I call it stealing
from from charity
but misusing charity money Trump had to
pay a 10 million dollar fine for
laundering money for an extended period
of time through his Trump Taj Mahal
casino that went bankrupt and so his
history with lawsuits is not very good
as far as paying the legal fees here
we all know what the most likely attack
will be from Trump or the tactic better
said he won't pay the fees he will then
get sued over unpaid fees he'll end up
owing more than if he had just paid the
fees to begin with but if and when he
ultimately does pay the fees it won't be
with his money it'll once again will
will be with donated money or whatever
the case may be and then the entire
thing will cycle once again we've become
very accustomed to this I don't expect
it to change anytime soon alright very
quickly this is just funny Trump during
his Ireland and I guess Scotland trip
that this trip is happening while uh
Trump's Civil Trial for rape and
defamation is happening in New York City
involving e Gene Carroll this is just
really funny
Trump walks through a room in Ireland
yesterday and a reporter essentially
says why are you in Ireland instead of
at your own rape trial and Trump says
well we agreed to come here Mr Trump why
are you here in New York for your civil
case please because we have a
low-standing agreement to come here
we've had a tremendous uh reception a
beautiful reception the people of
Ireland have been great
we have a tremendous success and I hear
we're doing very well
I hear we are doing very well in Europe
sir why are you here instead of at the
rape trial defending yourself well they
just rolled out the red carpet for us
here and it's been such a nice reception
I just absolutely love it a bunch of
interest it's sort of like beyond the
type of stuff we normally cover on the
show but a bunch of really funny stories
from this current trip to Ireland and
Scotland that Trump is on of uh people
flipping Trump the bird and you know
funny little protests that have been
following Donald Trump absolutely and
everywhere and so even this idea that
he's gotten a very warm reception there
as with most of the things that Donald
Trump says uh not exactly true not
exactly true we have a voicemail number
you can call that number any time of day
it runs 24 7. and you can really say
anything you want now a few things I
will mention the maximum voicemail
length is three minutes we never play
three minute voicemails on the show so
if you find that you're getting cut off
by the beep because you've used the full
amount of time
you're probably talking at least three
times longer than you should if you
swear it probably won't be used because
then we have to bleep it Etc
and if you're gonna criticize me please
criticize me for things that I have
actually done or said rather than things
that I haven't okay here is someone who
tuned in to one of our streams I guess
of a trump speech and didn't like how I
was treating the president
sorry the former they call him the
president uh the for the failed former
president of course I was watching on
your show the Trump speech yeah
irregardless of any political
affiliation
you were very immature and very rude
okay I guess that's it there's nothing
else yeah you know there I often will
get emails we'll cover some Trump event
and folks will search around YouTube for
a live stream and sometimes they'll come
across my live stream during which I
comment I give my opinion and my opinion
of trump is quite low uh I don't think
he deserves too much praise and
um as a result people will email me and
say how dare you disrespect the office
of the presidency and we shouldn't talk
about any president you can't be
negative you've got to be what are you
talking about what are you talking about
this is this this is the United States
of America we if if you want to talk
about decorum and tone your real concern
should be the way in which Trump's lack
of decorum
uh completely debased the office of the
presidency for four years folks are
worried I'm mean to Trump yet they
weren't worried about Trump mimicking a
disabled reporter and the thousands of
things that he did give me a break guys
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today it's really a good one oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad today's bonus show
we're actually not going to make money
on but we are going to discuss
um it turns out that that billionaire
Harlan Crowe Clarence Thomas's friend
paid School tuition for some kid that
wasn't isn't uh Clarence Thomas's son
but that Clarence Thomas sort of was
like bothering it's a it's yet another
really weird story involving Clarence
Thomas number two Republicans are
Furious that Joe Biden is sending troops
to the Border even though it's what they
wanted now they're mad that it's
happening okay and we will discuss the
new Utah law that has now gone into
effect
requiring all sorts of verification to
browse pornography websites it's wacky
what is going on socially in Utah it's
one of the most backward States socially
in the country and we're going to talk
about that and much much more all of
those stories on today's bonus show
which you can access by signing up at
joinpakman.com full price is a great
deal
but you can use the coupon code 24
starts now 2-4 starts now all one word
no spaces uppercase lowercase doesn't
matter 24 starts now will save you about
50 off of the cost of a membership we'll
see you then and then back tomorrow on
the Friday
foreign